Uh, Luke says, ah, I didn't say in the zoom, all I asked is, yeah, you need to do that.
It's part of the script. Luke, make sure that you let them know, because that's an objection,
right? Every objection that you're going to get, you want to, you want to eliminate it in the setup
and the setup. Part of the setup is the screencast. Part of the setup is getting on the phone with a
business owner. Sometimes I bring it up on the phone call before. I sometimes bring it on the
screencast. Sometimes I bring it up on both, right? But if I'm getting that every single time,
I'm definitely bringing that up. And I'm going to construct it in a way that doesn't feel like
I'm going to force them to do it, even though I am going to. And then if when push comes to shove,
we get to the call and they start telling me, Hey, I need to think about it. No, no, no,
I told you it's not, we wrote, man. You, you heard me. I told you on the phone. I told you
on the screencast, we don't do that. So, and then I'm going to hear them out, but I'm going to,
at the end of the day, I'm going to hold them to the fact they got in this call, knowing that I
don't do that. That's all I asked them and they agreed. And I'm going to get a decision. If they
say they want to think about it still, I'm going to say it's a no, I'm not going to let you think
about it. That's just how it rolls. I'm going to the next person. I'm sorry. Okay. I'm too valuable.
I'm a 10. You're a five. You have a commodity. I have something you need. I'm out. Okay.